[Music]
hello and welcome back to another
episode of beginner breakdown my name is
always is Alex mullering and I'm excited
to be uh working with you tonight and
we're excited to have a lot of people
here in the class but whether you're
joining in person or online always happy
to have you our topic tonight is puzzles
now last week we talked about puzzles 2
and we talked about the problem with
puzzles which in my view the biggest
problem with any puzzle whether you do
it from online or from a book is you
know going into it that there is a
solution and so part of the way that I
like to mitigate that because obviously
when we're playing in a regular chess
game you don't know if you have a
winning sequence or if not was the idea
of tactical signals those are really
important and we might touch on them
some here
but that was more like kind of
addressing this negative problem and how
do we counteract that today I'm going to
talk more on the positive side other
than just being fun how can we use
puzzles to improve our chess and I have
kind of two different methods that I
found work really well for me and for my
students on how to actually engage with
puzzles if you're looking to use them
not just as like a fun Outlet obviously
that's fine but also to actually make
progress in your chest proficiency
uh and those two ways are kind of fast
mode and slow mode there's you can use
whatever terms you want but we're going
to look at some examples here and kind
of work through both methods
in fast mode your goal is to as
accurately as you can but also as
quickly as you can solve a puzzle
usually what you're going to do is pick
a easier puzzles like you can lower the
ratings on some of the different ones
and you want to do as quick and as many
as you can as accurately as you can some
software is also like chess.com I think
has something like puzzle storm or maybe
leeches or that's leeches chest icon has
a similar one but whatever you engage
with but just trying to solve them
quickly in slow mode you want more
difficult and complex problems that are
going to take you a little longer to
solve and the idea for mixing it up is
you're practicing different skills when
you're doing a puzzle very quickly what
you're looking for is building up
pattern recognition by seeing the board
and seeing a pattern that is familiar
and how you can apply this specific
position an answer that you use in the
past when you're trying to do it slowly
obviously that is involved but you're
adding in visualization calculation
right and you're enhancing your ability
to see different variations on the board
obviously all of this is going to depend
on your skill right if you're just
starting out
maybe don't do anything fast maybe just
mating ones you might try doing quickly
but otherwise taking your time is going
to be important for all of them if
you're like an 1800 then you might be
solving puzzles instantly that other
people you know would take a few minutes
on so I've tried to tailor it for a
beginner level audience tonight but
we're going to go through a few
different kinds first round I'm going to
ask as I pull up the puzzle for anyone
in the audience anyone online as well if
you think you know the answer go ahead
and throw it out you don't you want to
be quick but you want to be accurate and
let's see how we go so here's our first
example here I'm going to hide this so
it doesn't give away the answer to you
all all right position one white to move
if you see it feel free to shout it out
white to move
and you can raise your hand or just
shout it out yeah Bishop to
Bishop four uh yeah Bishop to C4 very
very good
our idea here for those unfamiliar this
is a pin
a pin is any time that we attack
multiple pieces in a straight line and
the less important one is in front and
can't move out of the way of the attack
or else the more important one behind
gets hit so
if this type of puzzle is one that you
would struggle with then you would
naturally I would recommend
you working on this more as a slow
puzzle right taking more time and trying
to figure it out but if you're familiar
with pins as you saw someone in our
audience was today it's not that hard to
see oh I noticed the king and the queen
are lined up that's always an important
signal and so being able to launch a
bishop over here where it's defended is
going to win us some pieces now again
someone who's looking at this trying to
get more information if you take your
time with this you notice there's a lot
of important details right there's
potentially a battery against our King
so if we moved our Queen it would be
Checkmate and our Queen's also not
defended so there's a lot of danger in
this position we're down a full piece so
if you don't find this tactic you could
be in trouble and if you're not
confident doing it quickly you want to
take some more time
okay here's our next one everybody ready
it is white to move
see if you can find the best move for
white
yes what is the idea
very very good
Bishop to H7 sacrificing the bishop for
the pawn with the key idea that we are
deflecting the King right it cannot stay
on the Square it's either going to have
to move to h8 or more likely take our
Bishop but it is on either of those
squares no longer able to perform the
important function of Defending The Rook
so after the king moves we can pick up
the rook and we have won a rook for a
bishop and a pawn
I'm sorry we want to rook in a pawn for
a bishop so a really really powerful
technique again if this is the kind of
position that might take you a while
that's okay you're free to sit with it
but when you're working on a fast puzzle
hopefully you have some of these
tactical ideas in mind and you can start
to recognize oh I know it's a deflection
I see I have a forcing check right
forcing move something you always want
to look out in these highly sharp
positions and we can then lure the king
away from where he needs to be
all right let's do number three here
white to move
accurate but as fast as you think you
can find it
so
Queen takes Knight what's the idea
yeah this is like a lot of different
things happening we are essentially
removing two Defenders of this bishop
and we notice that whenever we take this
bishop with check it's also going to hit
this Square so we're both removing the
Defenders of the bishop
so again maybe deflection or undermining
and we're also making a queen sacrifice
to attract our opponent's Queen here a
lot is going on right it's a complex
position and if you need to right you
can always spend time to break it down
but the idea again what we're trying to
build up is this pattern recognition you
see a position like this and if you're
able to solve it quickly you know that
that pattern is pretty well ingrained in
your mind and you're looking at the key
areas of the board
uh so yeah really really nice once again
idea is this queen is overworked
overloaded she's defending too much and
we can pull her away so that we can fork
and win her back momentarily
yeah we're gonna pick the queen back up
I should have said that but the queen is
now forked and uh we have uh eventually
net we get both of these pieces and we
lose our Queen but we get their Queen so
we basically get a knight and a bishop
um well intrinsically removing two
queens isn't actually going to change
anything but it does matter when one
side is up material or has some other
advantage in this case we go from a
position where you know black is up two
points uh so we have a pawn for their
Bishop into one where we are now ahead
material and so when you're ahead you
don't want your opponent to have strong
pieces because it gives them greater
chances at creating counter play right
the simpler a position is the easier it
is for the side with more material
all right really good we got two more
examples of this fast version and then
we're gonna slow it down a little bit so
if you're having trouble keeping up
don't worry uh here's our fourth fast
puzzle
it is white to move
you want it to be accurate
but you want to see the pattern as quick
as you can
um
okay what's the idea
yes so we have another sacrifice here
that is leading to ultimately a
discovered attack we notice that this
bishop is pinning our Knight to the
queen
but a bad pin is really in my view just
a discovery waiting to happen so this
pin is not very good because this bishop
is not anchored to anything nothing is
keeping it safe and so if we can find a
way to move our Knight with tempo
we'll be able to take this bishop and we
can do just that we give up a bishop
but one upon
and if our opponent takes I mean if they
don't take I guess they don't have to we
might be able to try something that
probably doesn't work but if they don't
take we just want a pawn and they can't
castle if they do take
then we have check and we are going to
pick this bishop up next they even if
they wanted to try and be greedy and
still take the Knight it wouldn't work
because our Queen defends and the bishop
defense so probably they just need to
hide
and we win back the bishop but we gained
an extra pawn and their King cannot move
so kind of the the stuff that I see here
right again to look a little more deeply
as we see this this pin that's also sort
of a discovery waiting to happen and
especially this weakness on F7 right the
F7 Pawn like the F2 Pawn right both
f-pawns are much weaker especially early
in the game than anything else because
they are the only pawns defended just by
the king and so they are a good kind of
way to poke at the king and get to him
cause him a lot of problems
so I think the problem with like the
there's kind of it's not quite a legal
setup but it's close to the problem with
this idea which looks really nice right
is now oh they win the queen but then we
get checkmate it's a really pretty idea
the problem is here I believe they can
just capture our Knight and they defend
everything
um and we just lost the night so if that
Knight couldn't get involved that would
actually be a really nice idea too in
this case it doesn't quite work out that
way but that's another area where if we
have kind of lots of patterns that we're
recognizing being able to quickly
discern which is the best one and which
one actually applies and what nuances
might complicate it is also really
important another thing we can kind of
learn from doing these puzzles really
quickly
okay but great idea all right last one
and then we're going to slow it down a
little bit in this puzzle it is
black to move
why
this is a really funny one because I've
had students look at this position for
several minutes and really really
struggle and then you realize oh
this Bishop's not actually defended so
we can just take it because there's an
absolute pin on this pawn it cannot move
or the king will die again something
that if you're not aware of the
different tactical motifs like pins and
forks and skewers building those up
slowly but surely right with longer form
puzzles is going to help you but once
you have those in mind you want to be
able to try and apply it really quick
because that way the benefit to this is
a few fold one
if you play games that with quick times
like Blitz or bullet or wrap it even
being able to find the right pattern
very quickly is obviously very useful
chess is a game where time matters quite
frequently so being able to use your
time efficiently and sort through the
right patterns is obviously very helpful
also it demonstrates Mastery right the
more you're able to solve puzzles at a
higher and higher rating level or more
complexity the more you can show to
yourself where you're learning and what
you're still struggling with
so yeah really really that would be my
recommendation for how to use puzzles
quickly which I think is kind of the the
default for a lot of people maybe some
of that is cultural you know just we
live in a fast-paced world but
I do think there is also a very big
value to balancing this with slow form
puzzles and here's kind of the first
example again some of you might know
these pretty quick but for those who
don't we're going to take some more time
on these so so please don't shout out
the answer for this one
um
in this position it is light to move and
while you're thinking on what White's
move is
what's probably happening is because
we've just done a few puzzles fast a few
different ideas are immediately jumping
out to your mind you might be thinking
oh I see maybe a potential pattern here
or one here that's good what you want to
do with these puzzles and the way I do
it is I'll go to these same websites and
I will select a harder type of puzzle
one that's more complex for me
and then I will take a look
if you see the answer right away that's
fine but usually selecting a harder one
means one of two things either there are
some really sneaky themes that might be
easy to miss
or and I find this one more common it's
more than one or two moves you might
have to visualize a couple moves out
because there is some Nuance in the
position that means it looks like
multiple lines are good but only one
turns out to be
so I've been talking for a second uh
what are some of the ideas here anybody
have any ideas without necessarily if
you don't know the full line what are
you thinking
okay uh which Rook right here to E1
okay so I like the idea of causing a pin
right we pin the Knight to the queen and
maybe we have a lot of attackers there
might be a slight issue with the tempo
of this move because we're making more
of a long-term threat we're going to try
and take this piece but black has a
threat immediately accessible to them
right what is black threatening if it
were black to move what would black play
most likely maybe there's some crazy
better move seems like the most natural
move would be Rook takes Queen
so I like the idea of maybe setting up
some pressure on the e-file but I'm not
sure we have enough time given that
our Queens Under Fire and this is one of
the hints that you might be dealing with
a tactical position right again we know
this is a puzzle we know there is a
solution but in a real game you just
might just be in this position
and one of the hints that there might be
a tactic for you to look for is when
there's a lot of pressure right a lot of
things being attacked a lot of things
may be in danger that's a time where you
should slow down a little bit and try
and find what's really going on so other
thoughts for for white here
okay so Queen takes uh Rook here on f8
yeah so Queen sacrifice what's your
ideal with that sacrifice
okay so this is really really
interesting so your idea is we have a
lot of things lined up on this file if
we can take this Rook we might be able
to then you know lure the king to that
square
and move our Knight somewhere out of the
way to make a discovered attack right
this King will be over here our Queen's
out of the way so our Rook will attack
their King
and our Knight now while they're dealing
with the check can attack their Queen
we're trying to pick back our uh pick
back up our own Queen
this is a really interesting idea but
there is a little more Nuance to this
position
so that I like your idea but let's look
a little closer what might we be missing
here
and this is where we really want to put
on our visualization caps so I would go
through that whole variation
I think I'd probably agree to
five
no 95 I'm sorry you're good
no yeah 3d5 okay he's protected by the
ignite yes
and then see how courageous they are
well that's not a bad idea
um sometimes when you're not sure the
best move in this case uh our Queens
defended we they could take we could
take back we could get into some big
trade it seems like unless one of us is
missing something that would be an even
trade right we would lose a queen they
would lose a queen nothing else really
would be trading maybe our night gets a
little more involved but this is an even
game so whenever we have a chance to
look for something that gives us some
material or a positional Edge that would
be my start this would be a good like
fallback if we look and say I'm looking
for a bunch of moves and I'm not finding
anything good we have a nice natural
idea
we can sorry go ahead like so examples
of my
life then they can just like move to F7
yeah and we have something that maybe be
a slight issue right the fact that what
normally looks like oh well if they
block with Queen F7 we win the queen but
now I have to think wait we're
sacrificing a queen so we have to do
some calculation
if we play Queen takes Rook I like to
win I have a big trade in a variation I
like to kind of go one step at a time
and think what did I lose what did I get
we get a rook
King takes we lose a queen okay
Knight to D4 check they have to get out
of check if they block with Queen to F7
we can take it with our Rook
so we get the queen back Queen for Queen
we still are up a rook
but we just took it with a rook so they
take back
okay our Knights hanging and we probably
have to move it somewhere
and it's just kind of even right it
looks really good but it evens out in
the wash so using we have some patterns
here right we're seeing is there any way
we can improve on this idea if not we
might have to look for a new one but I
don't want to give up so easily I like
to stick with one forcing variation
until I think I've exhausted it
so White's moving correct yes it's right
here tomorrow
so again
and see what how
well it's not a bad idea but remember
when we're in a sharp position we always
want to look at our opponent's threats
so if I play Rook to D1 with either of
these Rooks they probably are still just
going to take my queen right they have
this rookie that's looking to jump and
take so and even if I go work to D1 I'm
not really even threatening to win a
rook because it's defended so not a bad
start but to me the queen is a pressing
issue someone in the chat it's a long
name I'm not going to try it starts with
I was on so whatever whatever your name
is maybe it's different
um
like it could be I was once or I don't
know uh
ins his suggestion or her suggestion or
their suggestion is instead of going
Queen takes King takes Knight to D4 if
we play Knight to G5 we achieve the same
thing but the Knight also covers F7
okay this seems like an improvement but
we have to go a little bit further
right Queen takes because there is still
another move right they now they don't
have to go to F7 but what if they play
Queen to F6 right now our Knight misses
it and if we trade Rook for queen
we're still just losing
um
a rook for it's still just a trade so
have we actually improved
is there anything we're missing there
and this is a more complicated position
there's a lot of subtleties but
this Nuance is really important to press
our visualization
so right now we should like think about
this line that you mentioned
yeah I would recommend sticking with
this idea of Queen takes f8 King takes
it seems like there's something here
this unless we exhaust all the forcing
moves I think we should keep sticking
with it and see what we can find
it seems like there's a lot we know that
if we play Queen takes Rook at the very
least we break even right because we're
getting a rook and we're eventually
going to win this Queen by some night
Fork
the only downside is right now every
line we look at we also lose our Queen
and our Rook so it comes out as a wash
if we can find any way to gain something
extra with this whole trade it's worth
it and the value with doing it in a
trade right the reason we're looking at
a line like this as opposed to something
like Queen E5 or Rook to D1 something
like these is because our lines are
forcing it's not that forcing moves are
better but they're better for
calculation because our opponent has
less they can do to deviate right if we
played Rook to D1
um they could take our Queen but even if
that wasn't an option we would still
have to think okay what if they trade
what if they don't what if they move
their Knight what if they move their
Queen We just have to calculate a lot
more if we think I'm going to play Queen
takes f8
there are two moves we have to think
about King takes and King runs away and
if the king runs away we just want to
Rook so we really only have to think
about King takes so that's the value of
a forcing move here
so I like to exhaust the forcing Moves
In A variation that I think might have
something if I go through all of them
and say okay I don't have anything here
that's when I start to move on obviously
if you have time pressure or something
you have to make different decisions but
with the luxury of time and my advice is
to treat this like you're in the middle
of an intense classical game you've been
playing for half an hour but you have an
hour on the clock or something like that
and if you find the right move here it
could be the difference between winning
and losing you have time
how do we use it
okay
okay really nice and this is kind of the
final key to the puzzle right what's
really happening here there's a whole
lot of things right we're attracting the
king to a square where our Rook will
make a discovered attack that allows us
to get some kind of fork in some cases
um
but what's really amazing is this whole
line despite all these sacrifices and
discoveries it's not about the Queens
it's not even about the Rooks it's
literally just about this night because
he's not going to be defended enough
here's the idea
Queen takes Rook okay again if King runs
away we just want to Rook so King takes
if we play Knight to D4 then the queen
blocks on F7 and it's a wash we trade
Queen and Rook for Queen and Rook but if
we play Knight to G5 our Knight defends
F7 so you can't block there and attacks
this Knight
so if the queen decides to block
obviously if you go to F7 or F5 The Rook
takes for free but if you go to F6
we can afford not to take because the
queen is pinned to the king
she will be stuck because again she
can't move we're gonna get her later but
we also get to pick up this night
and when we do so we actually land with
a fork we're also going to be picking up
potentially another piece now probably
not because they'll recognize they're
going to lose something and force this
trait now to then save The Rook but even
if they do that
we still have a rook
versus a rook and we have this extra
Knight versus some pawns uh and it's up
a piece
I've had a lot of students who tried
this is especially true with younger
kids because they you know just want to
find the right answer they get a little
frustrated sometimes with being patient
but I think this is an excellent
practice to be able to look at a puzzle
and say I think I see the right move
and then to hold off for a second right
because we had the right idea Knight
taking the Rook sacrificing it and then
making a discovered attack with the
Knight that picks up the queen was more
or less the right idea there was just a
Nuance with it we had to apply which was
okay if you block it's an even trade so
we switch targets
this is not something easy to solve very
quickly and so that's why I think it's
very valuable to be able to spend a
little more time and to really work on
that visualization because this it's
very hard to find the answer here unless
you realize oh once the Queen and King
are traded or once the Queen's straight
for the rook and there's a discovery we
can if we pull this queen away she stops
defending the Knight and there's a
discovered check and it's the queen will
be pinned to the king if she blocks
right being able to see these little
nuances in visualization take a lot of
time to develop but I think one of the
really important ways to develop your
visualization is to work on puzzles like
this and a longer slower more complex
way
okay enough on this example let's jump
to number two
again it is more complex than it seems
if you think you see it right away
then power to you but take a closer look
and make sure you're not missing
anything white to move
and
find the best move
okay so I will agree with you Rook to B7
is very very much the most natural
looking move right we have a bishop
that's beautifully lined up on the long
diagonal with our opponent's king
and our Rook here on the seventh rank it
was just a huge Target so Rook takes B7
we take check
and that's a good start from that
position black only has one legal move
our Rook is defended the king cannot go
to the C file because of our other Rook
so after Rook takes Pawn
the King has to go to A1 or sorry A8
but the question is
now what
okay Rook to E7 what's your idea
okay so this is a really good idea we
want to move our Rook to get some
discovered attack right because our
Bishop will call check and we're gonna
be able to you similarly to last line
right when our Knight moved the Rook
call check against the king in the last
example our Knight was free to kind of
attack whatever it wanted because it had
to save the king in this example we're
looking to do the same thing we're going
to move the rook and the bishop gets
alive now here's a question for you
does it matter if we go to E7 or to D7
because in both cases we're attacking an
undefended Rook
it seems like it shouldn't
but since we have the option maybe it's
important to look and see
so this is one important thing right
we're paying a lot of attention to the
Rook but we have to think what do they
do to get out of the check obviously if
they move their King in either case we
can just take whatever Rook we want but
we have this important move Bishop to D5
to block
okay how does that change things
resolution
uh give a check oh it's Bishop takes
okay
sure so that seems pretty interesting
um
there is another move we have to
consider that someone in the chat has
suggested
uh zobayan or band I'm not sure how to
say your name but notes that we also
have to look this Rook is attacking this
bishop
so now we also have to think wait a
minute when we move our Rook for a
discovered check what if they take our
Bishop how does that mess stuff up
and it starts to get a little more
complicated than we were prepared for
so having all of that in mind let's take
another look and see if we can figure
this thing out
similarly to the last time we found a
move fairly quickly that we thought okay
our starting move looks pretty solid
right last time we said probably we have
to take this Rook because we have a lot
of good options after that in this case
notice that we have not really suggested
anything besides Rook takes Pawn because
it just looks that good it's very hard
to say that's the wrong move
but we have to be really precise
so Rook takes upon
and it's a forcing move too so I would
recommend exploring it until we exhaust
it
King to A8
what uh King so after we play Rook takes
Pawn this King will have to hide in the
corner
yes
we also have this move right so instead
of going to one of these squares I'm
attacking a rook we can also play Rook
takes B6
which normally would actually be like
the checkmating move right but in this
case because we said well there's some
blocking and some maybe even worse
taking options
a little more problematic someone in the
chat
with the name generic name that's really
funny suggests Rook cheeks B7 King to A8
and then Rook to E7
because if Bishop D5 to block we take
and Rook takes E8
okay
so yeah their suggestion is we go
through this line and go back to E7
because they don't think blocking works
right if Bishop blocks then we can take
with check
and we still get to take this work in
the end
that makes a lot of sense to me
uh
we also want to consider what if they
take our Bishop when it is check because
blocking is one of the options but what
if instead they play Rook takes G2
best
to in the very Corner either by
and checking with Brooke from where
uh
this one or the bottom one yep take the
pawn at the B7 right and the only thing
that he can do is move into the corner
and then uh move the
um
tape or group they broke out of the way
and check them again with the bishop at
G
two
see what I mean yes yes so yeah you're
you're basically
yeah we're gonna lock the king in the
corner so it looks like we've basically
resolved the major difficulties here
let's take a look and see what's
actually going on so this is pretty
naturally our starting move right Rook
takes here and the King steps over and
now we have this beautiful uh Discovery
setup whenever we move our Rook the
bishop attacks and the question is where
do we put our Rook right B6 normally
this would be like our checkmating idea
and this in this case because the we
trapped the king fully but the problem
is it doesn't work here
because they can counter make a
sacrifice of their Rook for our Bishop
and if we take our work still hanging
and notice black is up a lot of material
so we can't do that idea
and similarly Rook to D7 has the same
fault right we attack this undefended
Rook but because they can move it out of
the way and capture our Bishop the same
thing's going to happen right we lose a
bishop and if we take
um
even though they're not getting a rook
in this case and their King is still
fairly badly placed black still has a
slight edge here we have two Rooks
versus one rook and two Bishops so
probably the two Bishops Are Better Than
The Rook
plus this Pawn difference
but the real solution here is instead it
was actually our first suggestion but I
wanted to not just give it away I wanted
to be a little more challenging so you
still would have gotten it in the game
is Rook to E7 because here the problem
Black Faces
is if they take our Bishop to get out of
the check
right again if they don't we just take
and we're happy but if they play this
tricky move
then we don't have to take their Rook
First We Take theirs with check
and then we still get theirs on the next
move
so now it's two Rooks versus two Bishops
it's a rook versus a bishop twice and
we're winning in both cases
and if they try to instead block uh this
also doesn't change anything because we
can take here with check
and still get this rook in the end
so again the the point I want to
emphasize here is not necessarily
whether or how quickly or how well
you're able to solve this puzzle but
more just the value in once you start
with the pattern right the natural
instinct is to see the pattern hesitate
a little bit and say okay is there
anything I'm missing a really good
question I found to ask is after I
finish a line that I think this is a
great line I'm going to get an advantage
or a Checkmate or something is I say did
my opponent have any alternatives and
I'll go move by move so here after takes
I'll say did they have any alternative
to moving the corner in this case
legally no that's the only legal move
after this move did they have any
alternatives well they had a few right
they could move their King they could
take our Bishop or
um they could block with multiple pieces
and so you need to consider all those
possibilities even if you think oh I'm
good no matter what sometimes you could
get in trouble like in this one where it
looks like it's the exact same
but then we end up in a lot of trouble
so being able to spend some time and
really work on your visualization being
able to see details of a position as if
it were the one on the board is integral
to your calculation and your chest
ability overall
um I have some more of these examples
that I want to go through but I actually
want to deviate very quickly and we
actually just might spend the rest of
the lesson on this is one final piece of
advice and you can relate it to both
fast and slow
in preparation for this I was just kind
of going on Lee chess and looking at
some different puzzles and trying them
out to see what I thought would be used
for this class and I ran into this one
which stopped me for a moment I was on
doing the fast puzzle section and then I
hit this one and I had to take a second
and try to figure it out
and if we want to try and solve this one
I think it'd be helpful and then I want
to show you okay what did I do once I
realized oh maybe this was a problem
area for me so in this case it's black
to move and the initial stuff I noticed
was material is dead even it's a little
unbalanced because we have a knight for
a bishop and white has a bishop pair
but material is technically even
and there's a lot of threats right if
this Pawn this Pawn is already a little
close to the edge and if it ever is able
to move there's a discover check this
Rook is trying invading on the seventh
our rook and our Queen are skewered
um
seems like we have a lot of problems
here
and I was trying to figure out what to
do and once again generic name in the
chat has the idea is looking at this
position they realized this King despite
all of the problems we have is actually
not very safe and we actually have some
pieces we can use our Bishop and our
Queen together if we have enough time
how do we get that time with a forcing
move in this case the move is Rook takes
G2
the idea is once we take this Pawn
we have the King has a few options right
if the king just moves the King has only
two legal moves right because our Queen
and then the Rook on this Square will
defend all of these squares so either
the king takes the Rook most likely or
the king hides in the corner
if we play Rook takes in the king hides
in the corner we can actually finish the
game in one move
with Queen to H2 Checkmate so you don't
have to worry about that one but we do
have to worry about King takes Rook
but now we get to activate our Bishop
and this king is too exposed Rook takes
King takes Bishop check and our Queen
and Bishop kind of dominate this king
the king only has once again one legal
move
and from here
we can make Checkmate in two anyone see
it how do we continue
[Music]
to or G3 G3 yep Queen to G3 check again
the bishop and queen dominating all of
these squares and there's nothing that
can block
it's almost mate the King has one more
move can hide over here on F1 but now we
can finish the game
with Queen 2g2
check mate
so I saw this puzzle and it took me a
second I was like okay I was able to
find it after a minute but only probably
because I knew it was a puzzle I knew I
was looking for a solution and so I'm
naturally gravitating to those more
flashy sacrifices and forcing moves that
I might not always be tuned into in a
real game and so I thought okay let me
look a little more into this and I went
down to the bottom once you've completed
a puzzle or if you give up and ask for
the solution it gives you some
information at least on leave chess I
think chess.com works the same and
probably other websites as well but it
told me uh this was an attraction puzzle
attraction is an advanced tactic which
the definition it gave
was an exchange or sacrifice encouraging
or forcing an opponent piece to a square
that allows for a follow-up tactic
basically what that means is we are
making some trade or sacrifice that's
going to force a piece to come somewhere
we want them to go so we can attack them
from that square think back to uh which
one of these was one of these fast
puzzles was a really good example of
that I think this one here was a really
good example where we remember we
sacrificed tonight to Fork the king and
the queen well we are oh the queen is
overloaded so she's a work sort of
Defense deflecting her but we are also
notably attracting her to this square
right she wants to defend the piece and
so we attract her here away from the
defense of the bishop and to a square
where our Knight can Fork her so that
would be kind of an attraction I
realized okay so that's the pattern and
what I did and what I think is really
useful too is I went to something called
puzzle themes now this is going to be
slightly different on different websites
I think on chess.com you go to puzzles
and then click custom and you can select
different themes on Lee chess you just
go to puzzles and click and then there's
a button that says themes but all that
does is it lets you set what am I going
to be working on here
and so I set a bunch for attraction and
my theory was if I look at this I will
go from having the slow mode where this
is something I don't intuitively grasp
and I want to get the pattern into my
head
into that fast mode where now I see the
pattern it's just applying it to
different positions so I want to work
through that with you a little bit and
see how that goes here is the first one
it spat out for me
in this position it is and I will put it
down to easy mode because I wanted to
see the ideas first this is black to
move
I think I moved
a work to be to attract the queen this
is an interesting idea so uh the not a
bad idea to trying to attack the queen I
don't know that we would really be
attracting her because she knows that
this Rook is defended
we can try and force it to move there is
a danger again whenever you're thinking
of making a threat you want to see what
your opponent's threats are and I
noticed that the white has some nasty
double drugs here that are kind of
eyeing down my d8 Rook so if we were to
play something like Rook to B8 we
actually might be in a little trouble
because they can take our rook and now
they're actually attracting us away
and it's going to be a Checkmate so not
a bad idea but we do need to notice
there is this threat so if our move is
not very forcing right at least not as
forcing as Rook takes the eight check we
might be in a little bit of trouble
um the other idea I heard was to take
their Rook so yeah forcing those are
always a good idea checks and captures
would qualify here so what's the
follow-up to Rook takes Rook
they they have to take back presumably
uh where
yes so this one again not super super
hard we have to look a little bit at the
forcing ideas but first we take their
Rook
and we are luring this Rook to this
Square where we can get a fork
forking their King in their Rook
whatever move they play
we now pick up that rook and we have the
extra piece our back rank is still safe
from this queen
uh so I thought okay so I'm learning a
little bit the first thing is I want to
look for potentially a capture right the
first one was a check right I had a
sacrifice that was a check in this case
it was just a trade so I'm getting some
more information about attraction for my
own pattern building I'm saying if I
have any option to to trade pieces uh I
should be looking at that especially
when right again when I say this is a
forcing move obviously white can play
any number of moves
but they're forced to take our Rook if
they don't want to try and be at a
disadvantage because if they just let us
take a rook for free they're naturally
got a piece at a disadvantage
okay here's our next one
it is white to move here
okay Queen to f8 King has to take only
legal move
broke to G8 and then the bishop will
have to block
and either one it doesn't actually
matter which one you take with but yes
really nice and this is a very nice one
because every move is perfectly forcing
black actually has no Alternatives
either one but this is another this is
the kind of position where I am not
probably in a real game looking to make
a sacrifice but knowing my tactical
signals and knowing I can lure this King
to a bad Square I have a lot of control
of these files
means that after we sack the queen for
The Rook
check and the king is getting back
cranked because after the bishop blocks
you can take with either rook and it is
Checkmate either way the King has no
escape and our Rooks defend each other
so I've seen now two examples where an
attraction led to a Checkmate right
looking at what pieces are near the king
because the king is an excellent tool to
try and lure out right he likes to stay
hidden away from attacks so the second
example involved the king
it wasn't about a Checkmate but it
involved the king being weak to a check
and allowing me to Fork but now I've
seen a few examples where I can also get
a Checkmate so all of this is just
slowly building up my recognition let's
do uh another one or two I will give one
this is kind of a funny aside
but this was the third example it spit
at me when I was looking for attraction
I I'm not actually sure this is
attraction so while you're thinking
about this one of the downsides is uh
the algorithms or whatever systems they
have set up to identify the themes
aren't always perfect
um so you have to you know be a little
bit generous with them and you know
sometimes he might not get the perfect
pattern building theme anyone see the
idea we should do for this one
it is white to move I should have said
yes we take the rook and again if black
doesn't want to lose it they need to
recapture
we take our second time and if they
don't want to lose that their King takes
and once the King has been lured away
the bishop is no longer defended now we
can't start this by taking the bishop
because then they'll just take our Rook
first and we have to take back and it's
even so we start with the most forcing
move taking their Rook
and I wouldn't call this an attraction
because we're not really like attracting
the king to a dangerous Square where
he's going to get tactic we're just I
would say this is deflection or removing
the guard from the bishop so not a
perfect example but the next ones it
gave for attraction so I think I did
yeah I did like nine or ten of these and
electrical Moon sequence not to gain
much in terms of strategic again
in my opinion
that's true but consider what we have
versus what black has right so we're
going to get a rook they're going to get
our Rook
we're going to get their Rook they're
going to get our Rook we're going to get
this bishop but we're still going to
have a knight
so black is only left with pawns
and we're left with pawns and our piece
so our Knight is going to be able to
jump around the sport and kind of
dominate these pawns and they're going
to be in a lot of trouble
so yeah normally when you can simplify
our position even if we don't have a lot
of Firepower left if we have more than
our opponent then they're doing even
worse than us
um so yeah again this one not a perfect
example of Attraction but most of them
were
um so let's go back to a few more of
those attraction examples just two or
three more and then I'll kind of give
some closing remarks in this position
white to move
foreign
and then
broke to A4
let them make the next move and then I
would attack the pawn as
A7 so you have a really solid threat
right the threat here on A7 once The
Rook is attacking it and the queen
together you have a check May threat so
I really like the idea here the only
downside is
um unless I don't have a better option I
don't like giving my opponents the
chance to find a defensive move so in
this case if we play Rook to A4 maybe
they just push the pawn to A6 and now I
don't really want to sacrifice it or
maybe they even play Pawn to B6 and let
their Queen defend so I like the idea
but we're I don't want to give them too
many outs so if we have a forcing
solution that doesn't give them any time
to deal with it I like that as the
starting point
so similar idea looking at the same
weakness but we notice because we have a
lot of Rooks on this line if we play
Queen takes A7 the King has to take
and the follow-up
yeah and so we're just switching the
sequence of your moves right your moves
were the right ones Rook here and the
queen but if we take with the queen
first now it's a sacrifice so we have to
calculate to make sure it works before
we put it on the board but because our
Rook on B1 guards this whole line we
actually basically set up another back
rank just on the side of the board the
Queen has to block and then it is
checkmates
so again you have the right idea you
kind of saw the pattern and now with
attraction we are again slowly but
surely building this theme you might not
be grasping it right away but my my
thought is that the more you work on
this type of problem the better you get
at seeing Oh I have a lot of pieces near
their king or oh I have a lot of
attackers on a square I can kind of
maneuver pieces to be where I want them
to get a nice attack
again this is a little more advanced so
if you're not seeing these tactics right
away that's okay but the idea is when
you encounter something you might
struggle with this is white to move uh
By the way when you encounter something
you are struggling with if you click on
the puzzle and set it to that theme
I think you have a much better shot of
building that pattern into your brain
which then makes visualization a lot
easier because when you see it in your
mind you'll recognize the pattern
any ideas here for white
because it's white to move here
to uh
H3
Queen to H3
it's not a bad idea you're putting a lot
of pressure on the H file but you
already have a good amount with the Rook
right and the Queen's kind of helpful by
guarding some of these squares so what
ways can we maybe attract a piece to a
square it doesn't want to be on
we want to kind of lure something out
it's white to move here
and here in the chat uh Master Vera
verdevich not sure how to say your name
but has a really nice idea engineeric
name following up we can actually make a
discovered attack on this King by taking
this Pawn
if we didn't have this as a discovered
attack maybe they could just take back
with the pawn but because their King is
in double check they have to lure their
King out so we've attracted their King
to get farther out in the open and what
we what we remember from the last times
are true doing this can lead to a
Checkmate or a really powerful attack so
how do we continue from here
G3 is really good but then we give the
king one Escape Square here on F6
Queen yeah Queen here
yeah F5 here and the king is in
trackmate so again slowly building up
that that learning now some people would
look at this method and say well hang on
if you know that you're doing an
attraction puzzle doesn't that defeat
the point of building up the pattern
like you already know what you're
looking for
I get it but remember what I said about
the problem with puzzles in the first
place right this isn't a problem unique
to puzzle themes the problem with the
puzzle is you know there's an answer in
this case we're just tweaking it so we
know a little more about what kind of
answer it is and the reason we're doing
that is to build up pattern recognition
when I would go back to the you know the
Speedy version of the puzzle I might not
keep the thing maybe I would at first to
get more used to it but I would
recommend most of the time when you're
then doing puzzles you can switch back
and forth between knowing what you're
looking for and just having it be a
random sequence of puzzles like normally
how it would be because then you can
start to again repeat the process you
figure out which ones am I getting
really quick which ones am I struggling
with and you target more of your time at
the ones you're having more trouble with
because it's going to help you build the
pattern and the cycle repeats this has
been really helpful for me and how I'm
using puzzles and identifying strengths
and weaknesses of my game knowing where
to spend time on study
and so I wanted to pass it on to you
we're going to go from these kind of
that have been a little more
introductory to one more on this
attraction theme that are a little more
advanced to see if you were to then
apply and take a little bit uh harder
one how might we try and solve that
so here's our position and it is white
to move we're dealing with the same
theme but it's a little more complex
than the ones we've been looking at
before and all I did that was just
setting the difficulty on the puzzle
harder
so again it's going to take a little bit
more time here but I always recommend
when you're working with a puzzle or
again theoretically when you're in a
game and you know you have a chance of
tactics because you see some of your
Tactical signals
to always start by looking then at the
forcing moves what's going to force my
opponent to respond in a very limited
number of ways as that's going to give
you the greatest ease when calculating
their options
Bishop to F6 looks like an excellent
start because we are forcing black in
two senses one we're forking the king
and the Rook more importantly the king
is just stuck right our Pawn this Knight
this king is just stuck so we actually
if we play Bishop to F6 Force the only
legal move the Knight has to take our
Bishop
so that's a really good start
it is a sacrifice so we would want to
calculate in our head ahead of time how
we might follow up that move
what might be the value of attracting
the Knight out of the way of the king to
this Square
uh Queen E5 not a bad idea right putting
more pressure on this night but um not
quite as forcing Ray it's not a check or
anything and there is some danger that
maybe now we're letting black make some
trades
and it's okay right it's easy to miss
something on the board so this is the
harder version right so there's more
Nuance in these positions
uh yeah Queen to E8 looks like a nice
forcing continuation so Bishop to F6
Knight takes Queen to E8 now this is
another sacrifice right because the
knight's now defending that square so
Knight takes C8
and now Rook comes into E8 Checkmate
from a back rank
so remember oh
because the pawn covers this Square so
we do need to do our homework right this
is a harder puzzle we need to make sure
black had no option to deviate so Bishop
to F6 Knight has to take the King has no
legal moves there's nothing else so you
have to take
Queen to E8 check okay Knight takes
or
Knight goes back to G8
okay okay well
what do we do there
they didn't have to take our Queen
yeah uh Arch Faye Sal if that's your
name uh has found the really beautiful
idea this position is actually not one
Queen sack we sack our Bishop
we sack Our Queen and they don't take it
so we sack Our Queen again with another
attraction remember attraction we lure
our opponent to a square they don't want
to be on if we sack the night we lure
the King right here with no guards ready
to be
back rank checkmated
no matter what they do it's mate by
force in this really beautiful position
so to conclude
I really hope this has been helpful with
how you use puzzles how you engage with
them in your chess practice whether
you're doing it fast to build up pattern
recognition and see how quickly you can
apply your knowledge to a given position
versus doing it a little slower taking
in the nuances of the position
especially if they're harder ones and
trying to build up your visualization to
just Aid generally in your calculation
abilities and then also mixing and
matching sometimes putting on a specific
theme when you notice an area or a type
of tactic you struggle with versus not
needing to do it in some cases because
one you want to get a nice smattering of
different things so you get more
exposure and are more prepared for
whatever situation comes up on the board
but also to identify those weak areas so
you can then go to theme and go back and
forth and cycle out that is all the time
we have for tonight thank you for coming
to beginner breakdown please stick
around because right after this our
grand master uh JJ will be here and we
are excited for him to be teaching I
don't know what you prefer to go by on
stream but yeah he'll be teaching uh
Grand Master's choice so please stay
tuned thanks everybody
[Music]